Metaphysical store
reality.
How it seems to have happened to us
is that over the last five years,
something like that,
we invented a new way of looking
at the world as a materialist
and that is exactly the view of story.
It's different than that.
It's a new technology and the problem
seems to be that the emergence of that
which has made us wealthy,
technologically powerful.
There's a,
he said,
boy,
fundamental way metaphysics
of our basic story
need to have this idea in the lady 1900
leaving that the conflict between the
scientists worldview and
the religious world view,
a designated religious will view
that.
He described that as the debit card
and he believed that because that had
happened,
we had lost our moorings or ethical
moorings and that our society is going to
wash away for that between
nihilism and totalitarianism.
That's a con and neat.
You died quite young,
believed that in order to recover
from that and find our marriage,
that we were going to have to replace
the gods that we once believed in,
let's say,
or your God,
but we want to plead it with
some notion of our own divinity.
Take responsibility for
creating our own doubters.
That was his idea is superman,
the Overman now yo was
very interested in niches,
diagnosis because he knew that we lived
inside stories and the stories had
certain accidents of value and then our
faith and our fundamental story had been
shaken not least by our scientific,
the rising of scientific knowledge,
and he was interested in trying to figure
out how people might find themselves
reoriented so they
didn't turn to nihilism,
let's say,
or two to telecare.
Ian Utopian world news bucket
put themselves back in the story,
but he didn't buy the niches prognosis
for cure because yoga was influenced by
Freud and Freud.
You out that
people didn't create their own values.
You can't do that because you have to
nature you and the nature manifests itself
within you regardless of your choice.
There's things that you can't
get yourself to do and know that,
right?
Because it was a matter of
creating your own values.
You just think,
well you can wake up one morning and
you could just tell yourself what to do.
Like go to the gym three times a week
so that you know you're in good shape.
Stop eating junk or quit drinking and
bang just cause you've got control over
yourself and well obviously that's just
not the case and that's because there
are all sorts of things operating inside
of you that have their own autonomy.
They're all own nature that you Glen,
he will have to contend with it.
So that's why you went back
inside the human psyche,
so to speak,
to look at the fantasies that
we spontaneously generated,
disagree with of the world,
to see if he can find out
what the pattern constituted.
Perfect.
Now I'm going to tell
you this little story.
So this is the idea.
This is partly,
he's stories are parked of your ride
from thousands or even can have tens of
thousands of years of watching how people
act it successfully and unsuccessfully
in the world and extracting patterns.
So the patterns get extracted,
they get more abstract and they
get less real in some sense,
but they get more broadly applicable.
So let me tell you first story.
So this is from the opening
chapter opening parts of geography.
So there's an idea in genesis,
this is roughly how the idea is laid out
and it's an idea that is expressed in
consultancy all over the
world in different forms.
So the first time you had is that
there's sorts of two domains,
major fee,
there's potential chaos and
there's order having more.
Okay.
Now that's,
that's the,
that's the structure of reality.
It's like the Dow was getting yet that's
the same thing that you're hemispheres
are matching order and chaos and
that's what the world's made up.
Okay.
I'm,
there's a third factor.
And the third factor is the thing
that immediately if we noticed too,
and that would be,
that's equivalent.
I think one,
one are people mean when they talk about
consciousness because that seems to be
what consciousness,
dubs,
consciousness establishes
order your conscious,
you make decisions,
you make it a world.
But while you're being
conscious in attempting,
you're attending what you don't yet
understand and haven't asked her.
So you face with something going
and potential and you transform that
effortfully in carefully
to what you understand and
what you couldn't have that.
So that's what your consciousness does.
And the Genesis you see that portrayed,
you sees death portrayed as something
that's defined because if dividing spirit,
so that's basically Gallois
y'all was y'all was,
what would you call it?
The process by which you all,
what generates the world
is being turned her.
This is the Christianization of that
story is the term of the logos and the
logos is the capacity for attentive,
communicative,
truthful speech.
And so there's a deep idea at
the beginning of genesis step
whenever defining consciousness
is that which uses truthful,
communicated speech to encounter the
chaos of the unknown and to transform it
and to have that border.
And so that's a technical description
of the structure of reality and it's an
ethical injunction as well because
what happens in the opening chapters of
genesis is that God use the logos to
create the world out of that preexisted
chaos and he,
and when he does that in stages,
he pronounces it good.
And so there's an idea
there [inaudible] idea
because one of the things
he might ask yourself,
and this is one of the things that the
mass murderers asking themselves all the
time is being justified or is it something
against which you should strive and
destroy?
And that's a very good
question because life is very,
very difficult and it's full of suffering
and it's full of new trail and it's
full of malevolence and it's
not an unreasonable proposition.
He questioned whether it would be
better if you're not thinking of all the
assistants and the people who take the
steps to doing the terrible things that
they ended up doing.
Answer that question in the affirmative.
They believe that life itself
is so unbearable in its
fundamental structure that
normally should it not exist,
but that the right response to it is to
take revenge against the fact that its
existence.
And that's part of the answer to how you
get to where you have to go if you're
going to render down and drive
it for camp blocks on the city,
on city sidewalks,
it's a deep,
deep bro and it's justifiable,
but the hypothesis it's
laid out in genesis,
which is an amazing hypothesis,
is that despite the fragility of the
world and the vulnerability of the world,
and it's called cleverly,
let's say towards malevolence,
if you encountered with consciousness
and counters the potential that the world
is extracted from and
he does that truthfully,
then what is created as
a consequence is good.
And I would say that's the host.
That's the most fundamental act of
faith and I think that's the fundamental
ethical question that lives,
it's that underlies the entire corpus
of the stories in which our culture and
all of them are paid.
The question is,
are you willing to act out the
proposition that being is good?
If you abide by the truth,
and what's interesting is that
it's an existential question,
Nate.
It's not a question that you can that can
be answered by fact because no one can
prove it to you because they can't.
They can't tell you what your life is
going to be like if you do that because
you're the only person that can find out.
And the only way you can find out is
essentially by risking everything you can
decide,
well,
I'm going to separately proposition
that truthful being is that being that
producers what's good,
and then I'm going to abide by that.
But then the springs
things will how to you,
because it isn't necessarily the case
that if you attempt to abide by your own
truth,
that everything that happens to every
second is going to be demonstrative proof
that that's the right pathway.
You're gonna get yourself
in all sorts of trouble.
If you do that,
you know that perfectly well because
there's uncomfortable conversations that
you should probably
have heard a few people.
And if you have those
uncomfortable conversations,
it's not like there's big,
it's just going to be roses and sunshine.
While you're having the discussion.
Quite the contrary.
The truth is a very disruptive force,
especially people that are
living inside an illusion.
And so it is,
it's a statement.
It's an,
if it's a metaphysical statement of faith.